So I've heard that YouTube sends new viewers to very strange places on YouTube.
Think about it. There's millions and millions of videos on YouTube
How do they know which ones to give to a new viewer?
Someone who's never been to the site before
Someone who doesn't have an account, someone who doesn't know where they're going.
How is the suggested system gonna toss videos at them?
That's the question
Because I've heard that it's not just weird places that they go onto Youtube
Cause there's some weird videos that I know and love
But sometimes it can send new viewers to places like
conspiracy theory videos
Uh - Racist videos, rants and stuff like that.
And it's like -- what I'm curious is like
if there's someone that wants to find those videos, that's fine.
But I'm curious to see how soon YouTube will send me to something terrible
and understand I'm not doing this very scientifically
I only have an incognito window up. I don't have like a VPN or anything. I didn't create a new account
I'm not on a new computer. It's my same internet
But it seems like this home page is a wide variety of just generally speaking
Stuff it -- eugh
Ewwww. Guh, ugh!
(laugh)
Beauty is not so beautiful. Oh my god, ugh!
UGH!
So it seems like it's just a general loop of this and - and I can test this out by
if I click on this and then I click on this, I click on this,Terry Crews
Whatever. If I go here to my home page, my home page will be different because now it will suggest things to me
it's got a recommended list and
Recommended is when it starts to think it knows what you want and that's when things can start going downhill
But if I control F5
Suddenly my - oh no, I have to close. Ok.
Google is a little stickier than I thought it would be.
If I close the window and open the window again
Bada-bing bada-boom. I don't have a recommended anymore
and then it's just an assortment of videos that it doesn't think I know I want.
So I'm gonna use this as my starting point
and - and basically this video is gonna be called like
"six degrees of separation from bad videos"
or it's like "how far down the YouTube rabbit hole there are until you get to shit videos"
or whatever this video is gonna be called
I don't even know anymore, but I'm gonna be the determinant on what - oh
No, don't wear wet socks to bed. Don't do that. No, that's a terrible idea
Okay, but I'm gonna start from somewhere innocent somewhere relatively simplistic somewhere that like shouldn't lead me to anything bad
Right? okay
Let's go ten amazing homemade inventions, which I imagine is gonna be amazing
It looks like a swimming pool. Yeah, it's um
Yeah, it's a it's a swimming pool. I mean, it's a nice swimming pool, I guess okay
So this is just a series of other people's videos that have been ripped from here. So good for that
All right free copper bar from a microwave oven. Please tell me this is gonna lead to minecraft of some kind
Well, that is some special that is a slice of some special. That's real neato.
Guy: Free copp-AH, so its a real easy job  and - and its "FUN" so even uh getting your free copp-AH the process of getting it is fun too and BANG!!!!. You've got copp-AH
Ok. Well that went places. What is this next video? What is this? How do we
What the fuhhh this isn't even in my language. I was looking at English. What is this? Why was this suggested?
I don't even know what's happening
Yeah, okay wipe that shit up I guess Oh God Oh Oh God. Oh that's sexual.  Oh you just
What? yes safety first Okay, that makes sense. I went for videos in I'm already in a different language. Oh god. What is this?
Okay. Oh.
uh, no- wha
(laughs)
And now I'm in flower arrangements, I don't know how I got here what the fuck is this
I'm just clicking on things that catch my eye. I'm not actively going anywhere here. I whoa, whoa hoa haha
Okay. Alright seems really dangerous. I don't know how I got to Bu Izci Ida
Kazaniyor Inanilmaz el ustasi iscileer.  I don't know how I got here
OK How did i get..How did i get hahahaha How did i get here
What are you doing? Oh I get it it's a compilation of people working quickly. Oh
Okay, I'm still in the wrong language what is that En Yaratici Fare Kapani Nasil Yalpilr? what?
Is this like.. is this a better mousetrap? Is that what this is? Did you just make it wait? No, you made it Coke and Pepsi
just to get people clicking on this because then you could put Coke and Pepsi in here didn't
Some fucking baller music, huh? Yeah, you did didn't you you wanted to get those keywords in there?
I know what you're doing here cuz I see in the suggest an easy bird trap technology make from Coca Cola and popsicle
Yeah, I don't care. Oh
Wow very impressive
Very impressive, okay
First step one drink your delicious. Coca Co oh, oh do it slower. Hang on. Wait, no
Oh take another sip. Let me get a good enjoyment out of this. Oh
Fuck. Yeah. Yeah slurp it down. You gonna eat the popsicle too?? - oh wait, let me get this in slow motion. Oh
Whatever Google is doing to look at me right now
They are fucking weirded out, but it is probably not the weirdest thing that they've ever seen. Let's just go back home
I want to see how it's changed. Yeah recomm- now I've got a recommended. Oh boy. Yeah now I've got some recommended and it
Oh, what is that I don't even OH What is that!??  that's horrible. Oh
My God look at the murder in this man's eyes. I've never seen wait three, two MURDER
(laugh)
Ive never seen - Oh my god, look at the
Suggested oh one of our most difficult earwax removals.
I didn't want this AS GYM fails!? that person's dying. Holy shit
I don't even know how this happened
Okay. Alright good God I still concerned in this man and like you know
I'm not unconvinced that it's not murder because look at what he's doing to this poor poor guy
wOAH HAHAHA AHH AHHHHHH
I Can't do that. Okay, I can't do that. Alright. Yeah, go back. Oh no. Oh god. No
No, my recommended is now Oh God. Oh, that's a splinter. It's still not good. I don't like that mask
I don't like anything about this. Oh
God, my recommendeds are fucked up hahahaha
What is with these five minute craft videos they're getting 44 million views I mean forget T series
They've got like 20, this is the same thing, but they got like 20 languages
And they're not five minutes!!!!
Its a lie!!!,oh my god.
Oh Yeah, yeah, wait wait
Fucking wait, wait a minute. Hold your goddamn horses. You think you're just gonna skate
I don't want to know what that is at all. I don't want to know I don't know where this went
I don't know how a go-got here, but I don't want to know what that is, but
You think that?
Calling for help in a drowning type situation is this maneuver?
It's like worse than an im-ph hahahaha
God no. Oh fuck me
Yeah pants. Okay, how do pants fix this problem from panic to cool calm and collected?
It's like two steps
It's like two..Oh
Right, okay. So so this lady right she sees her friend drop
She does a few jumping jacks to start off grabs and ears pair of pants ties off the legs throws it in
and the "only" answer afterwards
Is to beat on the water hahahaha
Which drowning woman would be able to catch a pair of flying pants
Good question, really good question, you know that is a good question. That's fucking hilarious
But also this was published a week ago
Forty four million views and I can see why I could see why YouTube got me here
This is not content. I want to see but I'm here
somehow
I'm here. I don't know how I'm here.
OH Wow great what is this? What is this? Oh
Wow, that was quite a logo
what language is this???????? im stupid ok
I Don't know what he just said, but it was probably very very
very something
Background: Discretion is advised
No way
Okay, wait
but speaking of disturbing material
And I really want to go down this rabbit hole because I think this is the type of rabbit hole
Well, that'll get me to the conspiracy videos. But what the fuck is this?
OH HOH
Stop there are 8,000 people watching this
8,000 people watching this and here we are
ohhhhhhhhh noooo
Okay, all right, I'm gonna forgive this one cuz this was made in like
2017 and that's when this type of content was at its worst. So I'm gonna assume that me getting to it is not indicative of
What YouTube is trying to push on people? It has no fucking clue what I want
I know YouTube is just panicking and throwing literally anything at me that I could possibly at all doc
OH, oh god, what is that? It has? No YouTube has no idea what I want
But this is what they have to contend with I suppose
There's some about like in the video I
Like I like a strong lady, okay. Alright, let's see how that changed. Okay, I you know, I'm very very confident in my
Masculinity and I'm not intimidated but oh my god. Okay, so
How long is it 20 up and doing this for 20 minutes? That's it, 20 minutes
20 minutes to send my YouTube recommended down a rabbit hole that they'll never come back from this is
This is irreparable. I mean even on my account when I'm watching videos if I watch one video, it's just
Instantaneously everything I could possibly ever want for that type of video, but now it has no idea
The language is wrong, like everything about it is wrong. Like these life hack things are wrong
Like one two, three, four five five of the ten recommended on this page are not English
Like I know there's a diversity of content on YouTube I get that and that's what makes YouTube great
Understandably it is what makes YouTube great
That is great about YouTube this so much that people can upload but at the same time, holy shit
How does anybody manage this and I didn't even get to a conspiracy theory video? Okay. This is not what I came to do
So let's back out. Let's blitz back up a few steps. Alright, I'm closing out of that one because holy shit
I have no idea what was going on there, but let's try this again
I'm hoping I'm hoping that when I open up a fresh page, it's gonna be a clean slate. Is it a clean slate? Okay
It's a clean slate. Okay, okay. It's a clean slate
I think so that was just with me going on the front page and I went down around
And honestly
Like I was okay
I was guiding it a little bit but I want to see how many videos it takes to get to a conspiracy
Theory video because that was the original intention but I mean it's going down YouTube rabbit holes are fucking weird
So let's start from somewhere safe
I want to start with somewhere very safe and we'll put up a counter here of how many videos deep I am
until we get to where we're trying to go for something flat earth or something vaccination related something like
9/11 maybe related some kind of conspiracy theory
That's what I'm trying to get to. You know, let's start with dangerous biggest heavy-duty hammer forging that sounds pretty cool
I'd want to watch that video
woah hoho hoahoahoahoahoah
I've never been more turned on by a machine. Holy shit. Oh my god Oh
Inventions, you wouldn't believe if they weren't recorded. Alright, what are they a
truck I
Don't believe it. I just don't believe it a
Really shitty truck. I have refused to believe this unbelievable my moments. You wouldn't believe if they were record
I'm down. I'm on believing. I don't believe it. I can't believe these moments. Oh shit. Well, alright
I can't believe that moment the mystery of the Holden Lake Barry Xie
Background: Four wonders among them is the mysterious hole in Lake Berryessa
Then Evan kilkis discovered something unexpected and what he found inside was truly outrageous
Uh-huh. Are we is this technically in the conspiracy theory genre? Because I think we might actually whoa
Okay, that's too much. Please stop this might actually be kind of conspiracy theory issues
So in the wake of the low water levels
The slipway was closed and eventually forgotten now in most cases slipways often run through sections of the dam wall or over them
But so it's a dam slipway
It's not it's not actually that interesting Oh the Bermuda Triangle mystery has been solved has it now, okay
All right. This region is notorious for its mysterious phenomenon, right? Okay
How many deep are we? we are this number deep
five
Not that deep. Okay, here we go. What really happened to Malaysia Airlines?
Okay. Oh, this is sad
What is this? What is this Encyclopedia Brittanica here? Why is this here? Why why am I seeing this? Ooh?
Information from third parties alongside videos on a small number of well-established historical and scientific topics have often subject to misinformation online
Like the moon landing. Ah
So that's a way to fight
conspiracy theory videos that's
Interesting. Ah
YouTube has protection against it neato burrito
Talk about clickbait CNN
Is that really the plane the nimitz encounter all strange events that occurred on Southwest? Oh fuck
Yeah, Oh, give me some UFOs. Oh fuck. Yeah. We're in UFO. Territory 10 things NASA doesn't want you to know
Oh, fuck. Yeah babies. NASA doesn't Oh, tell me number 10. Whoa drive technology
Forget the speed of sound we could soon be boldly going past the speed of light in the near future
With Star Trek style warp technology. Oh, wait. Oh wait
Okay, if we didn't think that we weren't actually in conspiracy theory territory top-five artifacts that true of past
advanced civilizations existed Oh
Million year old rock a mysterious gold man-made Bell encased in charcoal for millions of years
hundreds of small spheres with tiny grooves dating back to point eight billion years
These proof of past ancient advanced civilizations. No, there's a very easy answer to this
It's shockingly easy the results from iron smelting iron smelting alone leave
deposits in lake beds rivers all around the world if we did have a civilization before
We were here. We would know from those records the geological records of an advanced civilization
Creating iron. You cannot have a civilization until you get through the Iron Age like it's just how it is
Yeah. Anyway, I'm not here to disprove anything. Oh my God. Look at my suggested feed
Oh no.
We don't exist.
Four MEGALITHIC sites, that would CHANGE the history books. It's amazing. Unsettling discoveries that might change history
Oh
Shut up. What are they? Romans made it to South America. Okay. These aren't life on Mars.
Okay, that'd be that'd be interesting. Oracle bone writing? Okay. What are they HIDING on Venus?
WHAT are they hiding on Venus? what are what are they hiding on Venus? I'm curious. What are they hiding on Venus?
Okay, also also, by the way, we've already hit the conspiracy theory now,
we're going into the negative numbers or positive. The numbers have changed to color. Here they go again! Boink!
They're a different color now because, we're in beyond (Obviously!!!)
Territory
What are they... Wait? What are they hiding on Venus?
I'd like to talk about one of the most mysterious
And yet seldomly spoken about objects in the entire solar system. And so you may be asking yourself
well
What is so special about planet Venus?
And before we go any further and we get into the nitty-gritty of. No
I want to know. No. Stop. and so as I was explaining at the beginning of the video
And many of you will probably notice this to - was that there has been for years. Now what I have called a
blackout as it pertains to planet Venus and our attention has always been placed in the opposite direction
whether it be with visiting moons of Saturn or Jupiter and specifically
Planet Mars and so is there a blackout when it comes to planet Venus? Why do we never hear about it?
And is there a very good reason for that? And could it be that this mysterious planet? No. Venus.
I'm going to show you. Ok. Where is it? Hang on, hold on. Here we go
The reason we don't go to Venus and we have sent probes to Venus because fucking
462 degrees Celsius
The pressure is 9 point to the the the isn't the the atmosphere is like sulfuric acid
It's not a cool place to go. I
Mean it's a cool place to go. But I mean, it's not a fun place to go. It's real cool at all
It not fun. Buzz Aldrin. We're all in danger from evil at South Pole
This was such a huge news story and why hundreds of thousands if not millions
By now have read it and have been again put into fear
Having read it and are now worrying about this and are emailing me wondering what is going on and what I make of it
Okay, hang on we are all in danger
It is evil itself snow is fat check
No (laugh)
Then you can't trust nope, they're all covering up it's all part of a conspiracy
So, I don't know how I forget what the number actually is for how many it took to get to a conspiracy theory video?
But it wasn't a lot. It was not a lot. I went from metalworking. I
wanted to see metalworking
That was a... the YouTube rabbit hole.
Uh, I don't know what I'm going to call this video, but that was fun
And the amazing thing about YouTube is that you can make whatever you want. You can upload whatever you want
You can do whatever you want. Like, it's YouTube to make videos and you can put them up
That's the beauty of it
but with the beauty comes a little bit of evil and
with YouTube the challenge is how do you get someone to the videos that they
Actually want to see because most people don't know what they want to see until they see it. But does that mean
It should be so easy to get to the conspiracy? Oh
Well, I don't know. I don't know the answer to that one. But this was fun - thank you everybody so much for watching
I might do this again just because it's kind of fun just to see where the rabbit hole goes
How deep does YouTube want you to dive? Like where does it lead out?
I have no idea. If you've gone to any weird places on YouTube, let me know down in the comments below
Thank you everybody so much for watching as always. I'll see you in the next one. Buh Bye!